good morning believe nation today's
message is dream big over you Sal Khan
you know if I am Ana and I used to be
kind of quiet about this dream because
it seemed kind of like a crazy thing
maybe you know you even last year would
have seemed crazy for me to say what I'm
about to say but now I think there's a
potential for you know right now online
learning no one takes it see it
seriously they think it has value but
they don't the online learning is here
and your prestigious universities are
over here they're not in the same
conversation I'm hoping Khan Academy can
turn into an institution that I don't to
say rivals but it's talked in the same
conversation as some of these things
that have been around for places where
you can learn in the places where you
can learn you know at a very high level
so you could start at arithmetic but you
can go deep and it's a real learning
experience it's not something
superficial I think it's important that
round two hurts have big dreams I think
that's what keeps you going is what
keeps you motivated it keeps you excited
brings people on with you right if
you're just doing an average thing
you're trying to be an average company
you're just trying to make sales people
don't want to join that right people
want to hop on a mission right they want
to feel like they're doing something
important I look at this business trying
to dance salsa here right most people
would look at that and say hey okay you
got to get more students into the school
and that's great yes it's part of our
businesses we need to get more students
but I'm drinking bigger right I want
this to be a tourist attraction I think
most retail stores are boring I look at
the other stores out here and they're
all boring stores I go down Yonge Street
which is you know the biggest street
most famous street in Canada and most of
the stores are boring right I want
something interesting something
different I need to design my retail
space to be special right I want to
create an emotional reaction when
somebody walks by my storefront how do I
do that that's what I'm working on I
want Taylor Swift to when she comes to
Toronto her tour to come and take a
dance lesson at Toronto Day and salsa
right and mostly well that's crazy how
you gonna do that it's not even on their
radar
because they're just thinking within
this really small window right you got
to think bigger you got to have
something that motivates you and
inspires you to build something amazing
and realize that you have the potential
to not only build something great for
yourself but have an impact and have a
ripple effect through the community so
don't be afraid of your big dreams
because you have it and people tell you
you can't do it you know I tell somebody
I want to have Taylor Swift come and
learn at Toronto dance also people gonna
hit crazy Taylor so it's not gonna come
there right and I can either accept
their view and their limited thinking or
I can believe in my big vision and go
chase it and you had that same choice
too so the questions that a today is
what is your big dream leave in the
comments below I'm curious to find out
I'm gonna join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
a vinspresso